two years after her sister went missing
natalia de oliveira still hopes
her body will be found some families in
the town of brumagino are continuing to
search for the remains of their loved
ones
that were swept away when the dam
collapsed nearby my sister can be
anywhere
in this search for lacilda i come and
pray hoping to find her as soon as i can
there's a lot of possible areas we don't
know if they're here
we pray for everyone to be found
when the dam collapsed at this mining
complex 12 million cubic meters of mud
and mining waste was unleashed
authorities say more than 270 people
were killed
but people here say that's a low
estimate and many more were swept to
their deaths atamayo fajeda's sister was
among them
along with other families he wants the
mind's operator valet to be held to
account for what happened
excavation efforts are still taking
not place did vale destroy my family
countless families were destroyed
the lives of many people today we don't
smile
there's only sadness the state
government is seeking billions of
dollars in compensation from ballet
the world's largest producer of iron ore
while the company's former ceo was
charged with homicide last year
no one has been convicted
although vigils and memorial services
provide moments of solitude and
reflection
many here still feel anger and they say
it's hard to move on
and move forward when no one has faced
justice
andrew chappelle al jazeera